Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie!
A lot of you guys were asking me to do a video
about the new Iron Man armor.
So here we go I'll talk about the new ultimate
Iron Man.
Spider-Man armor and then I'll talk about
the evolution of all of his suits from the
first Iron Man film there are now 46 47 if
you include this new version of the armor,
but we don't know the actual designation yet
so there's a new round of the Spider-Man giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video it's for
one of the new Hasbro figures which is what
this is actually based on this reminds me
of that scene in Civil War where.
Spider-Man walks into his apartment talking
to Aunt May not realizing the Tony Stark is
sitting there just talking about his day like
there's this sick car parked outside what
the hell's going on and then he sees Tony
Stark.
Oh my got there's a sick new Iron Man car
in Spider-Man homecoming.
So who knows when they're gonna reveal it
but it actually looks a little bit like the
ultimate Spider-Man armor mixed with the MCU
Iron Man armor designs in the thing about
the ultimate Iron Man color scheme is that
the movie itself is borrowing a lot from the
ultimates universe the ultimate Spider-Man
title with the character like Yankee who's
actually net leads in this movie, so that
is borrowing a lot of story character elements
from the ultimates universe.
It would make sense that they would borrow
a couple visual things to, so the Iron Man
armorers themselves have changed a little
bit with each movie you know within the Iron
Man franchise itself they change a lot, but
just within the avengers movies they get tweaked
just a little bit every new movie, even with
Civil War he gets a new version of the armor.
It is that there was so much stuff going on
in Civil War and not as much attention was
paid to the new Iron Man armor is you would
normally see in.
He wasn't even in the armor that much Robert
a Jr walking around onset's pretty cool to
when you watch them in the behind-the-scenes
you see that he's one of the few people that
does not walk around in full costume and they
got it down to a science.
So if you watch the old Iron Man films and
you look at the old versions of the armor.
It looks very different because it's practical
like it's actually him standing inside physical
armor filming scenes.
Nowadays they have it down to the point where
Robert Downey Jr can just walk around onset
super comfortable even if it's super hot in
the land is son and just film's scenes in
the ad the armor and postproduction, there
are number reasons why Tony Stark would give
himself a new suit of armor.
In this new movie whole thing, Iron Man three,
was that he was moving past that.
But then they explained when they got the
Civil War that he just couldn't leave it behind
like he just couldn't stop being Tony Stark.
So for everyone who is bummed out at the end
of that movie when he threw the ark reactor
into the bay.
That was just meant to be a bookend for Iron
Man if Robert Downey Jr didn't renew his contract
is actually funny story about that they'll
tell at the end him renewing his contract
for these new Avengers films but the way they
colored in this the red and yellow accents
on a gray base is just meant to accentuate
the red red for Spider-Man.
So the color schemes very appropriate to the
movie and whatever functions he's added to
it.
Probably have something to do with fighting
the Spider-Man villains animal theme villain's
even though it all flows from technology,
we talked a lot about how Tony Stark, Robert
Downey Jr the Iron Man movies are so influential
in the way that they built the MCU you mutants
over a box with the X-Men universe very organic
base.
You have the older Spider-Man films at Sony.
Very organic animal theme villain's you have
the DC abilities people like Superman having
abilities that flow from their biology then
you have the MCU with a lot of aesthetics
a lot of powers flowing from technology based.
Not because marble is producing Spider-Man
he is rogues gallery flows from that to, so
you have your technology-based vulture that
looks very.
Tony Stark should Towery inspired from the
Avengers films, so the whole idea here is
that this is a continuation of the Spider-Man
Iron Man story from Civil War.
Tony Stark is super bummed out.
So this is important ark for his character
in this film two as well as Spider-Man.
It's really.
Spider-Man's movie, Iron Man is just a guest.
You have to imagine that Iron Man is getting
his own movie broken up into a bunch of different
movies.
The way the whole kit is like everybody's
heard the story about how Disney doesn't have
the rights to distribute a whole film.
So they don't want to make it if they don't
have all the rights to their giving hold his
own movie just broken up into a bunch of different
pieces between Thor Ragnarok and Avengers
infinity war.
So because they have so many other characters
to introduce and Robert Downey Jr is such
an expensive actor, they just amortize the
cost of hiring him over the course of a couple
movies and I totally love it.
There's been so much Tony Stark now it's time
to focus on new characters like Spider-Man
and now they can roll them out with cool new
shiny armor.
The way you normally would, without having
him completely take over the entire movie.
I'm guessing that there's probably less than
2025 minutes of Iron Man in this movie.
And yes you will probably steal every scene
that he is in and just based on the trailers.
It seems like whatever this new armorers going
to be it's not can it debut till later in
the film, because in the trailer one they
have that opening clip with him from Civil
War.
Like they literally just copy and pasted some
of Civil War just to tell you where things
pick up in the film and then later when he's
swinging through the streets he's actually
wearing the old version of the armor to, so
it sounds like that moment with him swinging
around his from earlier in the film because
usually they save big cool reveals for later
in the film like after he comes this avengers
base or maybe after Iron Man decides he's
finally get to get up off his ass and help
Peter he keeps telling Peter throughout the
film to just chill out.
Don't worry about being it avenger.
Peter won't shut up about it.
I want to prove myself.
He keeps treating me like a kid.
So there's gonna be some big third act reveal
where Iron Man comes and helps them out and
then.
Spider-Man Lance the big win list to run down
of all the different versions of the Iron
Man armor they don't officially have a designation
for this new armor yet, but starting with
Mark one in the first Iron Man film you have
Mark one Mark two and then Mark three and
it, Iron Man suit you have the marked for
the Mark five the briefcase armor the Mark
six was the one that he used when he fixed
the ark reactor with the new power source
then and Avengers.
It was the modular armor that would attach
midflight using the nano probes then in Iron
Man three that was what really got crazy humor
that like what way overboard and obviously
was the hat tip to him destroying all them
at the end of the film like I don't need all
this crap.
So was Mark eight all the way up to Mark 42
Mark 42 was the armor the war for most of
that film the age of gold on armor was 43
the 44 was the Hulkbuster that was one of
the best reveals from that movie Veronica
Whited Joss Weeden name it Veronica this is
so great because Once upon a time Bruce love
the girl named Betty and Veronica is the opposite
of Betty Wright everybody standing run quickening
and
by the end of that movie there was a really
subtle change the shinier version of the armor.
It was the Mark 45 it was more powerful, but
that was kind of lost because it was so much
stuff happening on screen.
Then we get to Civil War it's the Mark 46
so even though his Civil War armor is obviously
very cool so is cool to see a new version
of the suit.
I didn't like the way they colored that film
so much.
They doled the red just a little bit and unless
you're watching the movie on like a really
good calibrated TV the color looks a little
off.
So it almost looks like this red version of
the toy armor.
It just returning it to a deeper shade of
red, which I totally loved.
So let me know in the comments what is your
favorite version of the Iron Man armor.
It could be from the movies from the comics
from anywhere I feel like Hulkbuster and the
extremis armor is still the two coolest armors
but is not going back to extremis anytime
soon and because Hoke is fighting for obvious
they were not can see the Hulkbuster for a
while either, but because Spider-Man is visiting
Iron Man at the avengers facility.
We might get a version of this scene here,
where he takes them through the new armory,
is this avengers base.
Now in the comics he does have a mobile version
of the armory, Iron Man doesn't walk around
with his suit on all the time.
But like we saw Civil War like he has a watch
the turns into the gauntlet.
So he does have stripped down versions of
the armor, for whatever he needs to do with
that funny story about Robert Downey Jr renewing
his contract with marble so he re-up for a
slightly different deal he readout through
both of the Avengers films which included
his time in Spider-Man homecoming the Civil
War stuff, but he hadn't done that before,
comic con a couple years ago.
So they wanted to make this big announcement
to if you remember the big special panel that
Marvel did with announce Black Panther they
announce Capt. America Civil War all these
big movies they announce Benedict Cumberbatch
as Doctor strange the reason they did that
we found out now is because they couldn't
do it at comic con the year before that, which
I think is funny Marvel is big enough they
have enough goodwill in the fandom that they
don't need to go to comic con.
But they do anyway, which I think is really
cool it in related Spider-Man Marvel news.
A lot of you been asking me about the story
of Sony selling the rights to their film business
and Disney may be buying that so that they
can get Spider-Man back Marvel does and earn
money on the Sony movies they earn money on
the merchandising.
So when.
Spider-Man homecoming comes out.
Whatever amount of money that it makes Marvel
will not see a dime from that the just get
all the money from this merchandising here.
See you can see how their really excited to
give Tony Stark all these new toys during
the movie that they can sell them in real
life is a whole bunch of Marvel comics news
about how their returning all the characters
the status quo.
Maybe I'll do a video about that this weekend
is a whole bunch of stuff going on.
So what can happen later tonight is because
it Star Wars Friday I'll do my new Star Wars
last Jedi video that will post in a couple
hours.
There's a Lego Batman Easter egg video that
I want to post that'll probably be Saturday
morning.
There's a billion Easter eggs in that movie.
It was crazy.
So congratulations to Ryan Barry, you win
one of the Spider-Man Hasbro figures is for
preorder Hasbro hasn't started selling them
yet.
So please private message me on the back and
my channel so I can get your contact details.
There was a new round that started in this
video.
If it doesn't get too crazy I'll post that
knew Marvel video this week and I'll announce
a new winner while you wait for that you can
click here for new iron fist footage and you
can click here for new guardians the galaxy
to thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see the next video!